bonjour bonjour
on va faire un lapin farci aux cèpes
c'est pas mon pays c'est un lapin qu'il
faut mariner avant
il faut préparer bien assaisonner et
mariner plusieurs jours avant mais vous
allez vous expliquer
tout alors qu'est-ce qu'il nous faut
alors il faut des cèpes il faut de la
vente fraîche il faut des carottes il
faut du laurier il faut du thymer il
faut de l'oignon et de l'ail il faut du
persil il faut du sel et du poivre et du
vin il nous faut un bon lapin mariné et
de la crépinette bien entendu la
crépinette c'est de la toile du ventre
du porte on va se servir vous allez voir
pourquoi et bien alors pour commencer on
va faire la marinade qu'on aurait dû
faire deux jours avant mais il faut bien
montrer comment il faut la faire alors
c'est très facile on prépare nos petits
légumes carottes oignons persil terme
tout ce que j'ai énuméré jusqu'à présent
voilà on met ça dans un fond de plat ou
d'une cocotte ça dépend de la grandeur
qu'on a nous on va faire comme ça et
vous nous avez ajouté du poivre en grain
j'ai remarqué qui se promène quelque
part par là voilà ensuite alors vous
poser à plat voilà
on met le vert on va le saler le poivre
parce que le poivre en grain ça donne
une saveur mais sa poivre passée il faut
mettre les deux
et on va saler notre lapin
un peu oui
normalement on va y mettre le poivre
voilà et hop ça c'est pas bien et on va
le mettre à mariner alors là on a pris
le couper tout entier tout entier et
normalement on doit le laisser combien
de temps dans ce jeu et une nuit minimum
minimum minimum très bien et bien nous
pour l'émission bien entendu on va pas
attendre un jour une nuit mais peut-être
qu'on va pouvoir préparer la farce
pendant ce temps bien entendu Maïté
cette farceuse que vous mettez dedans de
choses il y a déjà le foie je crois
qu'il est en train de sortir oui ensuite
on va y mettre du persil
on va y mettre de l'oignon et oui bien
sûr on va y mettre de l'ail
voilà et puis hop il est reparti et puis
c'est bon c'est bon il y en a assez vous
croyez là
c'est bon
qu'est-ce que vous allez rajouter dedans
après les 7 ça va c'est bon
c'est très bien c'est bon bien travaillé
alors on va mettre ça là-dedans
et ce qu'il ne faut pas les mettre la
graisse un petit peu à chauffer non je
sens que c'est nécessaire
voilà dans la poêle bon on malaxé bien
tout ça on va mettre un petit peu de
poivre oui moi j'aime bien quand c'est
relever
et les cèpes que vous avez mis vous les
aviez fait revenir un tout petit peu à
la fois
revenir un petit peu avant voilà très
bien et ben là on va les mettre dans
notre poêle oui
on va mettre ça
et il faut que ça revienne parce qu'à
l'intérieur du lapin
et vous comptez combien de temps pour le
faire
le temps que les oignons
on va améliorer peut-être un peu cette
farce Maïté avec de l'Armagnac que vous
avez fait bouillir et maintenant voilà
je vais flamber ma farce
voilà et bien
la cuisine
de brûler on va s'occuper de notre lapin
mariné voilà rien changé de couleur bien
entendu parce qu'il a trempé on va
enlever tous ce légume oui parce que
c'est du légume gardez précieusement la
marinade bien entendu on va remettre
cela paire sur notre planche oui et on
va y mettre notre farce qui n'arrête pas
de flat de brûler
parce que ça veut dire que c'est du
bonheur maniaque comme on ne résignait
pas sur les bonnes qualités nous
alors
et je vais mettre ma farce
bien dans c'est pas facile il faut pas
c'est pas difficile et difficile mais
après c'est pas facile
regardez ça rue de bière quand même pour
remplir à lapin ou pas
on va fermer après avec notre petite
crépinette voilà parce que
avec les mains avec les mains on fait
beaucoup de choses bien sûr
une fois de plus ça sent le rêve alors
là vous allez essayer de me tenir comme
ça oui et notre crépinette de porc
qu'on trouve chez les bouchées vous
demandez ça oui il faut presque le
commander parce que là il n'en a pas
toujours mais si vous le commandez vous
en aurez oui voilà on enveloppe
délicatement le lapin comme un bébé
pour les mettre des couches
bébé maillotine
et la marinade Maïté on va s'en servir
tout de suite
voilà toutes les deux
voilà et on va les y allez-y allez-y
contient ici
voilà c'est très bien
la pastille pour recouvrir c'est bon ça
y est c'est bon
alors on va mettre
dans la cocotte dans la cocotte
et puis on va mettre notre lapin joli
mais en maillotin voilà on va le mettre
ici c'est pour ça qu'il faut une grande
cocotte quand même
et voilà
fais dodo mon enfant et puis bien à tout
à l'heure combien de temps
laisser cuire tout doucement
alors on va le couvrir et voilà une
heure et demie au moins et bien Maïté en
attendant on pourra peut-être préparer
un petit dessert pourquoi est-ce qu'on
ne ferait pas un dessert qu'on oublie
oui nous avons mangé dans notre enfance
le pain perdu bien sûr c'est le dessert
des pauvres et qui est délicieux quand
même on va le faire il m'a été qu'est-ce
qu'il nous faut pour faire ce pain perdu
bon alors il nous faut du pain bien
entendu nous on a la chance d'avoir un
joli pain mais on peut faire rêver les
restes des peintures
après il nous faut du lait il nous faut
du sucre il nous faut de la vanille et
du rhum des œufs un peu de cannelle du
beurre et on prépare notre sauce on
mélange tout ça on mélange tout ça
bien sûr on casse les œufs on rajoute
tout le reste dans l'ordre qu'on veut et
on rappe la cannelle on peut préciser
parce que c'est de la cannelle en bateau
et pendant ce temps quand vous allez
faire et on va mettre du beurre dans la
poêle le temps qu'on coupe notre tartine
c'est peut-être pas que ça aille trop
trop vite
alors coupez le pain je vais prendre le
pain voilà c'est notre pain de campagne
quand on vous dit que c'est le truc de
le faire des pauvres et bien voilà
autrefois nous c'était notre dessert
alors moi mon père et ma mère ils ont
toujours appris fait la croix on fait la
croix maintenant c'est dépassé c'est des
body mais moi je la fais toujours merci
mon Dieu de nous donner notre pain
complet mais c'était ça l'idée moi je
n'ai toujours fait et puis c'est
toujours fait machine à la main mais
voilà oui alors on va verser celui-là et
on va faire une autre belle tranche
[Musique]
alors là on va tremper
notre pain oui ceci là on a la chance
on va se lire un peu mais sans toi là
voilà autrement
ce serait bien plus joli et ce serait
bien meilleur parce que c'est du point
de départ de seigle oui là et on met
dans notre poêle et c'est tout et on
fait cuire
voilà les gestes de la poêle
on fait cuire des deux côtés oui je
tiens pour que ça contienne bien peu de
temps ça va très très vite
on va tourner
le retourner regarder comme c'est joli
même pas assez de jus c'est dommage on
va mettre un petit peu plus de jus comme
ça par-dessus parce que le pain et
n'était pas assez raciste ah oui alors
il a absorbé
alors voilà ça il faut pas le faire
parce qu'il était passé assez dur assez
raciste avoir un peu d'omelette en même
temps que le pain
[Musique]
le lapin cuit Maïté
alors j'espère que vous le connaissiez
tous ne pain perdu et si vous ne
connaissiez pas il est bien temps
d'essayer dès ce soir c'est très facile
faites-le et régalez-vous à bientôt au
revoir
[Musique]